[Musik]
tief im osten der republik die lausitz
wo man konnte uns drauf und sagt hier
ist mein zuhause und das ist für mich
heimat ich bin richtig deute leute drin
ich bin mir hier in der lausitz geboren
heimat bedeutet für mich verbundenheit
mit einem ort mit einer kultur aber auch
ganz wichtig die menschen her
menschen mit tiefen wurzeln in einer
region mit herta vergangenheit und
unsicherer zukunft menschen die vor
zerreißproben stehen ich vermisse hier
irgendwo wirklich dass die menschen
zusammen spielen und sagen wir sind
insgesamt die lausitz und nicht ich bin
ich und du bist du und wir reden nicht
miteinander ist nicht mehr das wissen
wir aber wir kämpfen
dafür dass ich wenn ich einfach
untergebuttert werden in einer zeit des
unaufhaltsamen wagens
[Musik]
die lausitz liegt dort wo die republik
an ihre grenzen stößt in sachsen und
brandenburg
still demonstriert das kraftwerk
schwarze pumpe seine stärke energie für
deutschland nonstop lieferte strom aus
dem stoff den die natur der lausitz in
rauen mengen geschenkt hat und mit ihm
spätestens 20 38 schluss sein soll
braunkohle ein gedanke an den sich silke
butzlaff nur schwer gewöhnen kann denn
seit 38 jahren steuert sie ihren bakker
es ist schon irgendwie partnerschaft es
ist ja sehr hoch sehr großes gerät er
hat um etwa
arbeitsgericht und da kann man schläft
von karatschi wichtig es ist natürlich
ja ich bin ja eine beifahrerin oder mehr
geräte führerin und viele vergleichen
ihn so sagen ja das ist der mittels
bagger im tagebau welzow-süd und da sind
wir aber trotz alledem ihnen zu recht
stolz darauf
neben silke gibt es noch eine kollegin
hier im tagebau alle anderen kumpel sind
männer an diesem tag steht der mädels
bagger allerdings still silke und ihre
kollegen müssen ihn warten und
eigenhändig vom hochentzündlichen
kohlenstaub befreien kein zentimeter des
kolosses dürfen sie auslassen eine frage
der sicherheit
silke ist in der ddr geboren die wende
brachte schwere zeiten für den bergbau
seit 1990 verloren fast 90 prozent der
hiesigen kohle beschäftigten ihre arbeit
auch silke wankte um ihren job in denen
sie ursprünglich nie wollte
aber zu ddr zeiten war das nicht ganz so
einfach in solche lehrstellen und ja ich
war doch immer so ein bisschen
mehr das rosenmädchen als das als das
blumen- und
wirklich den tatsachen gelandet und man
muss sagen es mit herz und leidenschaft
zum beruf geworden
mit dem bevorstehenden kohleausstieg
versucht sich silke zu arrangieren was
sie schmerzt ist der umgang mit ihnen
den einstigen helden der
energiewirtschaft degradiert zu
klimakillern
es muss sich alles weiterentwickelt mit
innovativen energien und und wir haben
sogar
wasser was auch immer aber ich bin der
meinung das alte muss das neue betreten
bis auf eigenen füßen stehen kann und so
soll es sein das ist zukunft hier
wurde ist nicht mehr die zukunft das
wissen wir aber wir kämpfen dafür dass
wir nicht einfach untergebuttert werden
untergebuttert abgehakt auf wiedersehen
so läuft das
von politik verstehen sie nicht viel die
parteien würden allesamt wenig
perspektiven findet sich
perspektiven vor allem für die junge
generation
was in der lausitz seit der wende
passiert ist nennen sie hier
demografische katastrophe
deindustrialisierung arbeitslosigkeit
abwanderung
bis heute leidet die gesamte region
daran dass die jungen leute weg gegangen
sind die agentur comeback möchte das
ändern ihre gründerin gegen selbst bald
nach der wende
berlin/leipzig new york vor zwölf jahren
ist stefanie dann nach finsterwalde
zurückgekehrt die heimatliebe war bei
mir immer da auch wenn ich mir jetzt
damals sich vorstellen konnte jetzt
direkt zurückzukehren aber meine eltern
sind ja noch hier meine großeltern meine
ganze familie wohnt hier und meine
eltern haben zum beispiel gekochte war
und natürlich wollte ich dass die auch
junge leute als gäste haben das war
einfach auch existenz sachen jetzt in
der familie die mich bewegt haben ja
also hier kann er jetzt nicht alles
ausstellen was macht dann meine familie
hier seit sieben jahren berät stefanie
nun rückkehrwillige wie christoph scholz
er zieht demnächst mit seiner frauen
zwei kindern aus potsdam hierher das
leben in der landeshauptstadt sei teuer
geworden und wenig familienfreundlich
wir haben uns abgesprochen das ist
natürlich schöner wäre wenn die kinder
unserer kindheit mit romano bisschen
aufwachsen könnten das ist einfach ein
bisschen näher dran es bis nach potsdam
ist auch immer ein bisschen weit
dann gibt es noch eine entscheidende
punkt dass man halt auch eine halbe
million für ein ausland legen muss das
ist vielleicht möglich aber sind halt
doch nicht bereit das zu machen und von
daher ist es einfach schöner sag mal in
die ländliche region zu ziehen und
insbesondere auch in die lausitz
stefanie hat ein gutes netzwerk in der
region aufgebaut kennt alle schulen
kitas und sportvereine und versucht vor
allem bei der wohnungs und jobsuche zu
helfen
viele leute kommen ja auch her und
ziehen auch zu weil sie dieses
strukturwandel gerne machen möchten also
sie möchten halt nicht am fließband
stehen und möchten gesagt bekommen so du
machst das jetzt 20 jahre immer die
gleiche arbeit sondern diese gestalter
die braucht es ja auch und die fühlen
sich aber hier in der lausitz
wahrscheinlich auch wohl
eine wohnung hat christoph bereits für
seine familie gefunden seine frau hat
einen job er sucht noch beim gang durch
sein altes neues finsterwalde ist ihm
vieles vertraut
kindheitserinnerungen die vorfreude
wecken das ist nicht so dass in der
pampa alles tot ist das gar nicht
existiert es ist was da und man muss
halt was draus machen und wenn man es
halt wieder belebt oder weiterhin belebt
so soll es gut
nur 20 kilometer entfernt von
finsterwalde liegt an der hütte einzug
hält hier schon lange nicht mehr doch im
bahnhof ist seit kurzem wieder etwas los
ein berliner architekt hat ihn gekauft
und ist samt familie hierher gezogen
lebenstraum war einfach zum haus auf die
dauer von der natur zu haben also was wo
man ständig irgendwas bauen kann oder
was machen kann also nicht nur ja nicht
nur am haus sondern auch wo leute kommen
können und irgendwas veranstalten können
sich einfach treffen irgendwas
entwickeln und da haben hier
einfach platz und räume und es verändert
sich jedesmal
simons konzept er vermietet zimmer und
proberäume an musiker aus aller welt der
bahnhof liegt so abseits sperrstunde
genervte nachbarn und das ordnungsamt
gibt es hier nicht doch in das leben
abseits der großstadt wo sich die
familie erst gewöhnen
so
holz geschlagen und getrocknet und mit
dem holz rufen hier gewärmt das war neu
hätte ich mir romantischer vorgestellt
das habe ich viel arbeit
in sein architekturbüro nach berlin
fährt trotzdem nur noch selten vernetzen
könne er sich von überall aus an diesem
tag ist teammeeting auf dem land
angesagt mit projektpartnerin cordelia
polin arbeitet er aktuell an
stadtplanungs projekten in der lausitz
für die lausitz diesem stadtplaner innen
und architektinnen und es ist natürlich
super spannend weil die lausitz ist
jetzt glaube ich in deutschland der
transformation raum wo ganz viele
zukunftsfragen exemplarisch ausgetestet
werden also zu gucken wir kriegen wir
das hin mit der energiewende in regionen
wo die leute immer noch auf ein auto
angewiesen sind und gar nicht darauf
verzichten können oder wie gestaltet man
so eine landschaft die über so viele
jahrzehnte vom bergbau geprägt war wie
macht man daraus wieder was eine eigene
ästhetik hat was mich aussieht wie die
schweiz oder nicht aussieht wie die
uckermark sondern was ganz eigenes
landschaftsbildes
an diesem tag gibt es flammkuchen für
alle in der großen gemeinschaftsküche
simons familie steht hinter dem projekt
stadtflucht ihr neues familienleben ist
dadurch entschleunigt und zugleich
intensiver und dennoch ist es bislang
ein experiment ob sie wirklich auf dauer
hier im musik bahnhof bleiben werden
wissen sie noch nicht
ein mann ist ja nicht nur ein aus oder
eigentum sondern ist ja auch
personen also wenn die eltern noch da
sind oder die freunde noch da sind oder
alte strukturen noch da sind und das ist
im moment ja noch nicht so
schnell dann sind nicht hier und
freunde finden wir jetzt erst neu
deswegen glaube ich jetzt ist noch keine
heimat aber es könnte einer werden
[Musik]
posch auch so ein verlassenes dorf in
der lausitz es liegt nahe der
abbruchkante des tagebau welzow-süd hier
kämpfen zwei ihren ganz eigenen kampf
mit ihren ganz eigenen mitteln im
restaurant schneckerl einladen sibylle
tadge und ihr mann zu politischen
diskussionen mit kulinarischer
raffinesse wir wollten hier dem ort
wieder ein bisschen lebensqualität geben
der gasthof hatte geschlossen wir
wollten den leuten hier sagen kommt her
trinken wir wieder spricht miteinander
es ist aber dann so gewesen dass nicht
die leute aus dem dorf her kommen
sondern wirklich genieße die wir jetzt
mittlerweile auch ansprechen der
niedersachse alexander und die
lausitzerin sibylle sehen sich als
genussbotschafter
einst haben sie sich in der
anti-atom-bewegung kennengelernt
trotzdem ist sie will es heimatdorf
gemeinsam haben sie sich für die
rückkehr entschieden sie stehen hinter
dem kohleausstieg und wollen den
menschen vor ort neue perspektiven
aufzeigen oft stoßen sie dabei an
grenzen
ich kann verstehen dass die menschen
hier sagen wir wollen nicht noch einen
wandel haben und dass die sagen früher
war alles besser aber wenn ich dann am
flammkuchen offen stehe und das
teilweise höhere die alten opfers er
früher war es besser mich sind alle
gruppen so weiter dann möchte ich fast
nehmen sagen leute dann baut die mauer
doch wieder auf dann haben wir auch
wenigstens ruhe aber ich sage es da
nicht die haben doch gar keine träume
gerade die die da sitzen die reden nur
vergangenheit und egal welche
altersgruppe das ist selbst dir selbst
die jüngeren die überlegenen biete
dieser zelle für trabi wieder her
kriegen können wenn silke nicht auf
ihrem bagger sitzt ist sie meist mit der
kamera unterwegs wolkenberg heißt dieser
weinberg er wurde künstlich
aufgeschüttet wolkenberg heißt auch das
dorf hier bevor es ab gebaggert wurde
existenzielle veränderung in kürzester
zeit
da ja wir wissen durch den kohleausstieg
der bergbau dann
später 38
dann ist er in der lausitz eben nicht
mehr sehen wird das versuchen wir
natürlich so viel wie möglich wirklich
festhalten um
die änderung für die tradition natürlich
zeit und natürlich für die nachwelt zu
hängen
der wandel ist nicht mehr zu stoppen
das wissen die menschen in der lausitz
die herausforderungen sind riesig doch
sie eröffnen auch chancen denn wenn die
region 1 bietet dann ist es vielfalt wer
gestalten will findet hier raum auf das
zusammen wird es ankommen
das
[Musik]
so bleibt diese ist so wunderschön so
vielfältig so ein bisschen verrückt so
ein bisschen stur capri und stasi nicht
das würde ich mir wünschen für meine
lausitz und was macht eigentlich ja nun
für mich bei der auswahl ich habe ja die
menschen so unterschiedlich sind hier so
lieben das wäre so schön
man kann sich ja nicht aber wünschen
dass nur die sonne scheint aber
so ein bisschen schnell
[Musik]